please welcome devon franklin
hello hey are you doing it's so good to
see you
it's so good to see you too and your
beautiful wife was on the show
so um thank you so much for uh making it
a family affair
it was so wonderful to have megan on the
show
yeah she enjoyed it she told me she had
a ball and she was just so glad
that you had her so as a family we say
thank you true we appreciate
you keeping the door open for us oh i
feel the exact same way thank you for
letting me
into your family and i want to ask you
i actually put the first question
basically from what the intro was saying
you're telling us that we already have
the
tools inside of us what are they where
do we find them
i'm so curious i think that's such a
powerful
prompt for us humans yeah i feel that
everything we need is never out there
it's always in here
a lot of times we're looking out there
trying to figure that out i was like no
what's going on in here and so you know
this idea
you know i talk about in this book about
living free and expectations it's all
about starting here
and changing the way that we're looking
at things because if we're honest
the hardest person that we're on is
ourselves in the moment we can change
that perspective
and that perception of who we are
everything around us i believe starts to
change
one other thing i talk about this in the
book when we get on the plane
they say in case of emergency uh you
know the the oxygen mask will come down
you put your mask on first and you help
others
drew i thought first that was like the
craziest advice ever i said i would
never do that
if the if the plane was going down i
would help everybody else then put on my
own mask
and then i realized if i do that i might
die by the third person
but if i put my mask on i can help the
whole plane live
so it first starts with us making sure
that we are happy that we're content
and then we can freely help as many
people do the very thing that we're
doing for ourselves
well i get oprah and her point now about
uh you know i mean i always knew that
you were so
smart and when our vfs heard that you
were going to be on the show the
questions just poured
in um would you mind answering some of
our
vfs questions i don't mind at all okay
great perfect i love this stuff so much
i'm so excited okay
our um first video came in from jean and
she
says that she's at a crossroads in her
career let's take a look
i was able to get on my dream career
path fairly early in life
but lately it feels like i've hit a
roadblock seems like everyone's passing
me by with
amazing opportunities what can i do to
hit the reset button and get noticed by
my boss or is it time for
me to shift career paths what do you
think about that devon if she wants to
move forward in her career
she has to not only meet the
expectations of her job but exceed them
and sometimes those expectations are
unspoken and i talk about this in the
book
if you want to keep your job you meet
the expectation if you want to get
promoted you have to exceed
and you got to know what your boss's
expectations are don't worry about what
your co-workers are doing
don't look to the left or the right you
look straight ahead because you have the
power to determine your course
and too often you're looking over here
and you're going to miss it gene own who
you are
find the power within know what those
expectations are
and go crush them um okay thank you all
right we have another video from kim
who is ready for mr right
hello drew and devon i recently turned
40 and i thought i would be married with
children
way before now i started dating a guy
recently and we have a lot of fun
together
but i don't want to waste my time when
is it appropriate time to ask
where is this going oh
i am so excited to hear your answer
um you know listen i believe it or not i
talk about this in the book
do not create a false and unset
expectation based upon your age
love will find you no matter what age
because sometimes we create that
expectation oh i'm 40
and this has or hasn't happened and it
creates an unnecessary stress
that we got to get rid of in this
scenario don't worry about your age
but ask the question as soon as you feel
that this is the person
that you want to go deeper with where is
this going
once you know you are serious is one of
the most important questions you can ask
and whenever you hear the answer listen
please do not mistake what they say
because sometimes if you love somebody
or you really like them
they can tell you where it's going and
it's not where you want to go and you
say oh it's okay
i'll spend some more time with them and
i'll get them in that direction no
if they're not going where you want to
go just like you would get out of an
uber if it's not taking you where you
want to go
you got to get out of the relationship
if it's not taking you where you want to
be
okay that is a brilliant metaphor i
really love that
okay well everything makes so much sense
devon
and your amazing book live free is
available um right now today wherever
books are
sold devon thank you so much thank you
thank you
and my best to your beautiful wife megan
wow i'll give it to her thank you so
much thank you so much
thank you